[Música]
e tudo isso começa com a história de um
desafio foi levada a nossa universidade
lá pelos idos de 2005 por representando
um gestor de uma empresa mineração uma
das maiores do mundo que o coloca na
mira que nos levava um problema que era
nós precisamos de ter um projeto de
capacitação em engenharia de produção
para alguns dos nossos engenheiros dos
nossos técnicos lá será que a
universidade poderia participar disso e
nós fazemos isso fazemos isso há muito
tempo sozinho somente o tempo exatamente
com essa empresa com quem nós
trabalhavam 30 anos nós não éramos e não
só nossos ilustres desconhecidos no
parlamento né
e isso era uma era uma situação
absolutamente normal né
só que durante a conversa quase no fim
da conversa é essa pessoa ela coloca um
zoom na outra estão na outra proposta e
vizinhos assim olha nós estamos aqui
também apresentando prefeito da nossa
cidade lá em itabira eo prefeito de
delmiro é o porta de uma voz para eu
solicitar à universidade que a
universidade implanta um campus itabira
como itabira e eu lamento nem ouvir
falar de itabira o poeta maior 10 pouco
pouco mais do que isso né e demandas
para a universidade instalar campos na
altura existiam muitos dizem que vinha
resistindo porque nós achávamos que
tínhamos que ter alguma coisa muita
qualidade
até que esse senhor nos apresenta a
justificativa é ea justificativa foi
olha lá em itabira nós temos uma
situação econômica que é fundamental
mesmo de um bem finito da natureza que o
minério de ferro e quando ela acabar
possivelmente da beira vai regredir no
tempo inclusive no bem estar da sua
sociedade da sua comunidade do seu
cidadão das duas cidadãs e dos cidadãos
a universidade precisa ir lá nos ajudar
mas peraí fácil e simples extensão
pois é mas a gente
vamos mudar o perfil econômico do
município e isso é uma situação
inusitada né ser agente de
desenvolvimento econômico entidade
catalisadora de um complexo processo de
mudança não é bom só que tinha uma
vantagem que motivou alguns de nós que
era tá bom é difícil é um processo um
projeto complexo mas se der certo nós
podemos ajudar a mudar a vida de
milhares de pessoas para melhor isso
enquanto algumas pessoas entre os quais
eu não tenho privilégio poder contar e
aí é parece uma questão que eu acho que
vale a pena nós discutimos rapidamente
que é realmente uma universidade não
pode ser um agente desenvolvimento
econômico e sua própria universidade
ainda não aceita bem nem os seus
parceiros e também nos municípios e
também teve essa cessão do município de
itabira né
eu vou passar aqui alguns algumas
figuras algumas imagens para tentar
mostrar isso rapidamente nós a teoria da
economia diz que elas produzir alguma
coisa é preciso alguma coisa que chama
que se denomina de fatores de produção e
os três principais fatores de produção
santana trabalha capital terra trabalho
e capital era trabalho de capital ou
quem vamos ver se sempre foi assim e
esse talvez possa agregar alguma coisa
externa trabalho e capital
essa é uma região do mundo é que até o
final da década de 30
princípio da década de 40 era a maior
produtora da ameixa seca do mundo a
produzir um terço ea sua economia
baseada nisso nisso evidentemente terra
como fator de produção trabalho thales a
alta tecnologia de então 1940 um pouco à
frente nem a linha de produção que a
embalagem está certo alguém reconheça
esta região
bom eu tenho dois minutos e 35 segundos
essa região é o vale do silício val do
silício que vem mudando o perfil da
humanidade através de ondas de
conhecimento e tecnologia uma atrás da
outra
numa sociedade cada vez mais exponencial
o vale do silício via disso há quanto
tempo 1940 é possível mudar o perfil
traje dramaticamente em não muito tempo
o vale do silício hoje é isso que aquilo
aquilo estão os logos das empresas
tecnologia que habitam o vale do silício
e lá
a terra já não é tão importante como
fator produção lá
o trabalho é importante mas eu trabalho
intelectual que é importante
lá o capital é importante claro que é
importante nós é um outro tipo de
capital que alimenta esse tipo de
empresa né e alguns números mostram isso
dramaticamente as 150 maiores empresas
do vale do silício faturaram em 2006 o
equivalente à metade da riqueza que se
produz mesmo ano
isso pra mim é absolutamente espantoso
metade da riqueza do brasil foi
recapturado por essas empresas
em 2006 e um pouco das características
de uma cidade que tem o grande causador
tudo isso tem uma universidade a
universidade paulo alto numa cidade 70
mil habitantes no vale do silício em
itabira tem 120 e 130 empresas geradas
por essa pessoas que circularam por essa
universidade
foram cerca de usd então 40 mil empresas
faturamento dessas empresas por ano 2,7
trilhões de dólares anualmente
alguém sabe quanto o pib do brasil 2,5 e
2,7 trilhões dólares
se isso não espanta o que espantar a e
desde então gera empregos registrou 5,4
milhões de empregos é fazendo uma conta
rápida estudar as pautas a soma de gerar
por ano de empregos algo igual à metade
da população de itabira site
universidade não é gente e
desenvolvimento econômico
é e agora eu trago isso num caso
brasileiro evidentemente mais modernas
claro tem que ser mais modesto porque as
duas situações não se comparam
diretamente santo em outros tem exemplos
que eu não vou falar aqui porque não dá
tempo
nova santa rita do sapucaí em uma
cidadezinha lá no sul que chama railda
eletrônica 41 mil habitantes
lá atrás também é um grupo de 150
empresas 10 mil empregos e faturamento
2,2 bilhões de reais
tudo isso baseado em instituições de
ensino e pesquisa inatel fayet
então com certeza que não tenho dúvida
em dizer quando itabira faz uma aposta
de atraso universidade federal no estado
dos 15 anos a tecnologia no estado
empreendedor para que ela seja parte
importante da mudança do perfil
econômico do município que a
administração do então estava
absolutamente correta
a universidade pode ser que no caso
específico deve ser um dos principais
agentes da mudança do perfil econômico
do município
mas ela não faz sozinha ela não pode
fazer sozinho porque a universidade não
tem minha produção a universidade não
produzir prova lei então preciso agregar
outras entidades que sejam capazes 1 com
o universidad produzir do fato esse
desenvolvimento e tem uma teoria que foi
desenvolvida já no final do século
passado de que as entidades que são
capazes de fazer isso na mangueira
possível se juntam naquilo que foi
denominado de l striptease numa numa
numa é verão semelhança com a opção do
dna que junto à universidade do centro
de conhecimento que junto aos governos e
no caso específico é neste caso de
importância especial o governo municipal
que junta o setor empresarial
então isso é uma teoria do
desenvolvimento na era da economia
baseada no conhecimento produtos da
melhor maneira da maneira mais efetiva e
produtiva
se governos universidades setor
empresarial conseguirem trabalhar em
conjunto de maneira harmoniosa e com uma
cola que se chama confiança porque a
confiança quebrada o projeto não avance
em caso de exemplos disso um exemplo
muito
o interessante vou deixar para vocês
consultarem e da assinada no sedã que
tem na sua página principal nós fazemos
desenvolvimento econômico assim com a
hélice tríplice e ter lá um conjunto de
projectos muito interessantes para
analisar o universidad de
desenvolvimento econômico em
desenvolvimento econômico isso faz como
é e desenvolvimento tecnológico que faz
como né
eu vou citar aqui um caso dramático da
segunda guerra mundial
na segunda guerra mundial tem uma
primeira marca importante é que a guerra
não foi ganha pela força bruta dos
exércitos como agente anunciou hoje a
guerra foi ganha pela força
imperceptível da ciência foi a ciência
guerra querem ver durante a segunda
guerra mundial até então a humanidade
nunca tinha visto um desenvolvimento
econômico e tecnológico tão fantástico
lá foi inventado radar
lá ele foi tentou se inventar o contra
radar guerra eletrônica a propulsão a
jato aquelas bombas dos alunos
a aviação a jato no final no final da
guerra é a computação digital para
decifrar os códigos das mães avanço e
inimagináveis na aplicação da medicina e
alimentação aquelas latas da alimentação
foram inventados nã questão logística
pesquisa operacional o tema típico nerd
na academia e o grande destaque da bomba
atômica à bomba atômica que no fim
acabou por terminar a guerra do batom
única é que para desenvolvê la
o governo dos estados unidos alertado
pelo senhor alberto einstein todos vocês
conhecem decidem entrar num projecto
fazer a bomba atômica
quando todos os grandes físicos todos os
grandes cientistas inclusive a irmã
dizia que era impossível com o
conhecimento adquirido então
principalmente com a tecnologia
disponível produzir através de uma
reação nuclear
um artefato que pudesse fazer qualquer
coisa inclusive estude era impossível
exigir só daqui a duas ou três décadas
tem uma duas três décadas não é possível
fazer isso
o resultado é que do esforço feito
navegação talentos da disponibilização
de recursos financeiros não foram nunca
contingenciados da urgência em ganhar a
guerra para manter um mínimo de
população civilizada no mundo num
projecto trípoli seles juntando o
governo com a sua terminação juntando a
indústria com a sua com a sua força do
produto se juntando às melhores
universidades do planeta
juntando cerca três mil a 6 mil
cientistas e no pico de todo o processo
130 mil pessoas trabalhando no projeto
no fim com uma economia de guerra
enquanto a pior situação da economia
como também não há dinheiro para nada
a economia de guerra foi possível
investir lá com determinação política
com o tempo limitado precisava ganhar a
guerra com que custo
considerando o projeto um projeto
estratégico com objetivo claro
comprometimento do seu comprometimento
setores indispensáveis
não basta dizer eu vou colaborar têm que
se comprometer com a atração de talentos
3 mil cientistas os melhores do mundo né
itabira tem uma guerra para vencer com
talentos
é preciso atrair talentos e com a
participação decisiva nas grandes
universidades aquilo que em princípio
parecia impossível e que precisava de um
senso de urgência urgentíssima aconteceu
o impossível aconteceu
aí a universidade postando perante uma
situação que ir pra lá ajudar a resolver
um problema disse que sim veio aceitou
instalou no campus ac que vem
trabalhando junto com as entidades para
que na realidade é esse desejado futuro
brilhante de tavira se possa concretizar
com o outro diferencial é que o
município a vila tem um diferencial em
relação à maioria esmagadora todos os
municípios do país
ele tinha recursos extra arrecadados
daqui curso finito que vem sendo
utilizado e ainda é possivelmente o
maior patrimônio do da economia da
economia italiana tinha recursos que
foram destinados por lei exatamente para
preparar o futuro se vem sendo utilizado
ou não é outra conversa
mas eles foram reservados para isso e o
compromisso
o município é que os iriam ser
utilizados para fazer implantar
concederem e operar aquela que seria a
mola mestra do desenvolvimento econômico
do município que o campus da unifei
itabira é ali o governo municipal se
colocou ficou com a incumbência
disponibilizar a área física e construir
o campus tem que construir o campus e
essa contrapartida saíram do município
comprometimento com não não vou dizer
não agora eu não tenho e vou ter que
parar e tal em economia de guerra
a universidade que implantou um novo
curso e opera o campo se precisa fazer
muito mais coisas e o setor empresarial
e que o quer dizer que a empresa que foi
nossa parceira instrumentalizou
tecnológica nem todos os motores da
universidade
bom aí é ficar aquela pergunta que eu
fiz no início agora josé como é que a
gente faz isso em bonn uma coisa a gente
tem que fazer mais do mesmo não pode aí
o sangue diziam que era o meu dizia
insanidade é continuar a fazer sempre a
mesma coisa e esperar resultados
diferentes a quanta diferença aconteça
a universidade não pode continuar a
fazer a mesma coisa o governo municipal
não pode continuar a fazer a mesma coisa
que o setor empresarial local não pode
continuar a fazer a mesma coisa sobre o
risco vir somente aconteceria os mesmos
resultados não estão levando o futuro da
vida né e aí aparece então o projeto da
universidade
vamos fazer diferente o campus é
diferente a proposta do campus e
diferente da sua concepção é diferente
a sua construção e diferente dizem
armazéns e bonito mais a esse luxo os
demais não é
tudo foi feito nesses campos foi feito
com propósito e ela serve exatamente a
missão maior diz campos poder atuar como
agente de desenvolvimento econômico vai
construir um conjunto de salas normais
para crescer de aulas normalmente espaço
lo pesquisa nós nos laboratórios da
universidade não vai cumprir a sua
missão é preciso fazer algo semelhante
que está lá atrás
aquela linha barto a linha participar
para tecnológico tanto se discuta está
pronto é só investir aqui fica pronto
tudo isso eu digo é necessário e tem o
objetivo não foi feito pela beleza
e pela qualidade dos arquitetos que se
envolveram e para quem tem dúvidas
eu digo lá no vale do silício onde as
pessoas todas querem ele e participar da
grande mudança o verdão jogou seis que
estão mudando o mundo aparece um projeto
agora agora neste momento de atrair
talentos itabira e precisa atrair
talentos por favor consulte os campos
porque hoje estão fazendo no vale do
silício eu vou passar as imagens que
valem mais do que mil palavras
a linguagem ea gente está falando ou por
imagens porque ele tem muito tempo ainda
né
olhem a qualidade dos espaços vale do
silício para atrair talentos
vocês acham que isto está em perceptível
ele diz assim na realidade tornar um
sonho realidade só dependo de pessoas
que acredita ainda sonha mas tenho duas
coisas a primeira delas se quiser ter um
princípio na determinação da prioridade
dos projetos e tirando aprendizado de
algo que já vem sendo feito nos lugares
a minha proposta é que você não tem dois
princípios quando você tomar teve que
tomar alguma decisão importante sobre o
futuro de itabira pensa no campus
primeiro e pessoal de diversificação
econômica primeiro para fazer as
rescisões disso devem ser os princípios
que seriam adotados eu termino dizendo
de itabira não pode ser apenas uma
fotografia na parede e muito menos uma
maquete numa sala senão a dor do poeta
perdurará
muito obrigado